voilà on a été bousculé un peu dans le
temps mais les voici les voilà
tasha qui réside à montréal emmanuelle
latraverse et à tahoua et j'accueille
avec grande joie daniel lessard à ottawa
bonsoir à vous trois ça on va si vous le
voulez bien on parlait du niqab
incontournable on en parlait jeudi
dernier on va avoir des chiffres
ensemble rapidement si vous le voulez
bien
c'est assez ça c'est fera pas comme
chiffres de façon générale 72% de tous
ceux qui ont participé on parle de 13000
plus de 13000 personnes à la boussole
électorale 72% en désaccord 19%
seulement en accorde en désaccord avec
le port du voile qui cache le visage
pour les serment de citoyenneté
quand on fait par province regardez
c'est quasiment l'unanimité au québec tu
l'as pas en confiance le ca dépasse 89
pour ça au québec en alberta et prairies
72% également atlantique 68 ontario et
en colombie britannique on est le plus
déchiré entre permettre ou non le port
du niqab
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait à partir de
maintenant là on voit que les
conservateurs et que le bloc l'utilisent
largement ça va se poursuivre quelques
jours daniel s à écouter ya des
conservateurs qui pensent que ce dossier
pourrait leur permettre de se détacher
des deux autres est de briser cette
égalité ou les trois parties sont à 30 %
chacun si le rappeur est un homme
intelligent il sait comment fonctionne
la société canadienne il sait qu'il ya
un très grand malaise vis-à-vis ce
dossier là que beaucoup de canadiens
s'ils ne sont pas prêts à aller aussi
loin sur le chemin de la laïcité que les
québécois sont peut-être prêts à
pardonner plus de choses mais lors d'une
cérémonie de la citoyenneté ya un
malaise vis-à-vis ce qui s'est passé et
s'il viendra peu c'est très bien
également que en cour suprême
là dessus ces chanceux gagner ne sont
pas très grandes en moi qu'on fasse la
preuve absolue que lui ni câble n'a rien
à voir avec la religion musulmane donc
ils jouent le jeu politique
il va le jouer à fond ça peut l'aider à
remonter la côte ça peut aider le blog
le parti québécois même à faire élire
des députés au québec il les avait au
one pédestre et bonheur de sylvain n'a
pas un jeu politique
l'humain d'achat on le voit quand même
les chiffres en ontario et dans les
prairies
il ya une assez forte majorité qui
disent nous sommes à l'aise avec ça on
veut pas faire un cours de droit
nécessairement puis c'est peut-être plus
complexe mais il ya eu un malaise il ya
certainement eu un malaise et je pense
que c'est non seulement stephen harper
qui profitent de la remise cette
question devant le public mais sa nuit
aussi à son rival thomas smic r parce
que ça lui met dans une position très
difficile surtout au québec où et
messieurs vainqueur à sa forteresse avec
ses députés
la large majorité des députés ici qui
veut maintenir 10 ans que lui il est
contre cette décision beaucoup la
décision et compte la décision d'aller
en appel que on devrait être capable de
porter le niqab et prendre le serment ce
que le bloc effectivement va utiliser
contre lui au québec mais aussi que ceux
qui veulent lui nuire potentiellement
dans le reste du canada
alors pour les conservateurs s'ils
veulent baisser le score de monsieur
nicaise certainement quelque chose sur
lequel ils vont miser
ça s'appelle la wipeout x en anglais
c'est la division des adversaires
emmanuel on va écouter
parlons du bloc on va écouter quelques
secondes de cette publicité qui a fait
un peu jaser au cours des derniers jours
on est content vient tout de suite les
élections s'en viennent
puis si thomas mulcair est élu ya aussi
un beau groupe it link qui s'en vient là
ils sont en veux pas puis même si on
n'est pas d'accord avec le port du niqab
pour voter ou se faire assermenter
thomas mulcair lui il l'est c'est la
goutte de trop
je retourne ou blanc alors voilà on le
voit on
on met le pipeline et burqa et niqab par
dans emmanuelle vraiment on doit se dire
au bloc on y va à fond leur ai plus rien
à perdre le côté la dent de jouer le
tout pour le tout je voudrais ce qui est
remarquable c'est à quel point est ce
que révèle que la danse est avant tout
une question partisane et non pas une
question de principe je vous dirais sur
les femmes et tout le reste c'est que
justin trudeau aussi de ceux qui ne
s'opposent pas au port du niqab encore
d'une citoyenneté irait pas en appel et
vous voyez le bloc ne s'attaque pas du
tout ajusté de 1
il ne s'attaque qu'à son principal
adversaire le chef du npd monsieur
mulcair et il faut dire aussi que dans
tout ce débat là monsieur mulcair est
celui qui était le plus prudent est
depuis le début de la semaine dernière
bon il reproche à monsieur un peu de
faire de la politique de peur de
division mais il s'en tient
essentiellement à dire écoutez moi je
m'en tiens aux jugements des tribunaux
donc il essaie vraiment de ne pas entrer
dans le débat
c'est comme si le bloc essayait de le
traîner de force qu'ont eisner ou npdc
qu en ne jouant pas dans ce jeu là
finalement vont minimiser les dégâts
politiques si vous voulez de ceux de ces
dommages là et je conclure entend mieux
cotés risque est là dedans parce que
regarder les comtés où se développe peu
portée c'est principalement des comtés
où le parti conservateur espère faire
des gains est pour l'instant sur le
terrain les gains c'est au profit du
parti conservateur qui se font donc eu
un risque pour le bloc 2.2 jeu du
particulier les conservateurs eux
est ce que au canada anglais
tasha passez moi l'expression est ce que
parce qu'au québec la le gouvernement
couillard a décidé que les services
allait se donner à visage découvert et
être reçus à visage découvert donc c'est
un peu la phrase fourre tout c'est la
ligne a été placé là est ce que ce débat
là au delà de la campagne
est-ce que ce débat-là va prendre de
l'ampleur au canada anglais je ne vois
pas à ce niveau là par exemple en
ontario avec madame guen je pense à
aucune intérêt à imposer une loi
semblable et la discussion sur police
fermant la porte du niqab so lu ment
mais sur la décision
il a les accommodements accommodation
raisonnable pardon situés plus au niveau
de certaines instances qu'ils ont eu
lieu dans des écoles par exemple ou des
filles ont été isolés pour certaines
prières pendant la journée écolière il
ya des choses comme ça qui sont survenus
n'y a pas un énorme un mouvement pour
faire un débat là-dessus comme le québec
le fais et je doute fortement qu'on va
voir la même sorte de choses
les autres les premiers ministres n'ont
n'ont pas vraiment intérêt parce que le
débat n'est pas aussi à surfer ça demain
vraiment une question fédérale dont
quelles raisons c'est l'exception
québécoise daniel voici l'exception
québécoise et dans le reste du canada
pour ajouter à ce que dit h elle a tout
à fait raison
les libéraux de justin trudeau sont
mariés littéralement avec le
multiculturalisme
même si on fait de plus en plus la
preuve que ça ne fonctionne pas les
britanniques l'ont démontré à plusieurs
reprises ces dernières années mais les
libéraux y croit sincèrement et ils vont
suivre justin trudeau la suite en quarts
thomas mulcair problème qu'il est un peu
comme sur le pipeline
il faut qu'il fasse attention à ce
qu'ils aient au québec et dans l'ouest
parce que bon il s'est presque deux
versions différentes et la même chose
sur le niqab bien une aile gauche
faction très très très progressiste au
npd qui ne veut pas entendre parler de
ça et je me souviens mois deux voisins
je suis très content et de paul durand à
ottawa un néo-démocrate de connu qui
disait ce qui se passe au québec c'est
absolument épouvantable
nous on est très ouverts à tous les
immigrants donc macaire est un peu
coincé entre ces gens là et le québec et
son caucus québécois ils font caucus les
assauts de pardon ça va sortir pendant
les débats au québec qui vont avoir lieu
dans les prochaines semaines
je pense que ses répercussions dans le
canada anglais on va pas regarder ces
débats là parce qu'ils sont en français
mais les clips sur ça je pense autrement
être répétées dans les médias anglais
peut-être que certaines vont le regarder
quand même il écoute les des mangues et
nous on écoute les débats en anglais
revient contrat des f 35 annulé daniel
est ce que ça vous fait penser un peu
aux hélicoptères à l'époque les
développeurs de jean chrétien jean
chrétien qui allait annuler le contrat
de brian mulroney
il veut se départir de 478 millions $
pour l'annuler
dans ce cas si elle veut se démarquer la
partie en ce moment on a décidé de
remplacer les vieux seeking des
hélicoptères et aujourd'hui c'est passé
35 ans et il ya beaucoup d'experts qui
disent ah les contrats d'achats
d'équipements militaires au canada c'est
des modèles de ski ne faut pas faire on
n'a jamais vu autant d'improvisation
d'incompréhension bref des modèles à
éviter ils font de la politique c'est
venant après fait de la politique avec
ce justin trudeau aussi je cèdre d'eau
peut laisser croire
si on écoute comme il faut qu'il y en a
peut-être jamais d'avions militaires
devront acheter sous un régime libéral
si tu te pisse le penser cela il ya trop
d'obligations du canada avait envers le
temps et c'est assez de la politique ca
c'est de bonne guerre mais je pense moi
que ni apple ni trop d'eau vont
convaincre les canadiens là dessus
emmanuel depuis début mai ce trudeau qui
fait campagne presque plus à gauche
le port presque plus à gauche que que
monsieur mulcair c'est un autre exemple
qui veut montrer un peu lui il est pas
militariste à tout crin il va regarder
les contrats en tout cas de plus près
dit mais je voudrais que tâche a parlé
du web politique cela petit la division
sur le niqab l'on voit une tentative de
la part des libéraux de faire les choses
sur un enjeu comme les f 35 qui est un
enjeu donc ils les gens sont pas les
dents dans les rues à cause de ça mais
ça a été comme un boulet est de mauvaise
gouvernance que traîne le gouvernement
conservateur depuis des années donc de
sortir lathus une tentative de remettre
ça sur le tapis ce que de surréel la
danse c'est que à travers tout ce débat
là le gouvernement avait trouvé une
solution le finalement de confier sans
un secrétariat indépendant pour rendre
une décision rationnelle et réfléchi là
monsieur trudeau lui jeter aux poubelles
et le pire là dedans c'est que monsieur
harper pour marquer des points
soudainement lui qui veut pas parler des
f-35 des années une touche à 5 une pole
de 10 pieds aujourd'hui tout d'un coup
ils attaquent justin trudeau là dessus
et clegg finalement toutes les vertus
les retombées économiques de ce projet
la banque s'est vu ça où tout ne peut
aussi réelle de campagne électorale hier
permettez-moi va vous donner quelques
chiffres on va pas vous abreuver mais
quelques chiffres sur ce c'est un achat
gigantesque on le voit 25 milliards
c'est en 2010 quinn initial 65 avions il
ya toujours 65 avions en prévision on
est rendu à 45 46 milliards de dollars
ce coût estimé pour 40 ans pas juste
l'achat mais l'entretien donc c'est un
gros morceau la tâche et daniel oui
c'est un gros morceau et écoute les
choix sont là on pourrait en acheter
moins de ses avions si on voulait
conserver le chiffre initial ce que font
d'ailleurs d'autres pays revise le
montant d'avion qui vont acheter
mais moi je pense c'est un excellent
exemple de ce que la campagne des
libéraux fait sur plusieurs niveaux
c'est à dire la différenciation à tout
prix des conservateurs pour se
positionner comme le tireur parties ont
fait ça sur les déficits ils ont fait ça
même sur les réfugiés ont dit on va
amener 25000 c'est le plus de tous les
partis en première année et maintenant
ici et sa force monsieur mulcair et
monsieur rappelé dans le même camp ce
qui ne fait pas distingué monsieur
mulcair de monsieur harper alors cessé
incarner le changement mais comme
emmanuel a dit c'est tous à gauche le
parti libéral s'est pas de principe mais
c'est très électorale c'est bon calcul
je pense je l'aï évoqué oui là où il ya
des nuances qui manquent pas triste
c'est que quand stephen harper dit on va
perdre des tonnes d'emplois chaque fois
qu'il négociations de ce genre de
contrat là aussi toujours le plus
difficile la chape mans sur le contenu
canadien
que ce soit un gouvernement libéral
gouvernement conservateur aux néo
démocrates ils vont devoir négocier un
contenu canadien est par trop sinon il y
aura pas de contrat donc de dire on va
perdre des milliers de riverains la loi
ici si on annule le contrat complètement
et on en achète pas du tout oui il va se
perdre des emplois mais je pense pas que
justin reçoit aller jusque là il veut
juste savoir le processus de soumission
est allé au plus bas soumissionnaire
vous
la merci à vous trois îles manuel bonne
bonne suite on se revoit un peu plus
tard cette semaine
je vous donne 20 secondes emmanuel après
une semaine de terrain vous étiez avec
monsieur mulcair
et puis ça se corse
oui c'est une campagne qui se corse moi
ce que je remarque surtout c'est qu'on
lui toute une première phase de campagne
changement pas changement économie et là
vous voyez que ce soit sur les f-35 que
ce soit monsieur mulcair sur la loi
antiterroriste on voit le débat se
préciser dans les détails des offres que
font les chefs politiques si le prix
d'une campagne de 79 jours on peut pas
faire des annonces à tous les jours et
ça ça manque la barre pour les chaises
qui sont forcés maintenant de vraiment
expliquer aux canadiens et rendre des
comptes sur ce qui leur promettent très
bien pour vous aussi de leur faire
rendre des comptes jeudi à ce débat que
des anglais des anglophones écouteront
avec plaisir et passion regard du manuel